e e
[Music]
for
Christian
[Music]
hello everyone it's always helpful if
you turn the mic
on it is so good to see everyone here
thank you all for who came early for the
state of the table and all of you who
are joining us now you are so welcome
here at the table you are not only
welcome here but you are celebrated here
I wanted to give a shout out for
February being Black History Month uh 50
years after the emancipation of black
people in this country uh Carter
Woodward was a man who had a vision to
study the African-American life and
history and so that was the beginning of
what we are now officially Black History
Month that was founded in
1976 okay we have a couple of
announcements not your mama's Sunday
school class it's fixing to begin again
February the 23rd it meets at 300 p.m.
in the adult cross
room um they're reading through the
gospel of Mark it is a safe space and it
is open to hard theological questions so
so it is a perfect space if you're
deconstructing or wrestling with how to
view scripture or simply want to learn
more about the
Bible all right as mentioned a little
bit earlier we will be having a child
dedication ceremony on Sunday March the
3 so if you have a young child who is
not yet ready to be baptized but you'd
like to commit to raising them in the
way of Jesus
then go ahead and scan the QR code and
sign up for um that
activity if you are anxious about being
in a church setting or part of a
disability Community or are just feeling
fidgety today we have an accessibility
bucket available uh to you over at the
table to my left is it there I don't see
it
okay we will have one there
eventually
okay and so now if you notice we have
lit two
candles and these candles are a sign of
the presence of Christ Among Us Christ
fully
Divine Christ fully
human and now as we exit the k om of
noise and hurry and
productivity we will enter The
Fellowship of
Silence
Stillness and
simplicity we will enter a Sacred
Space a place for prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold
Christ the revelation of
God the heartbeat of
creation so now allow The unforced
rhythms of Grace to find you to hold you
to love you to mend your
heart may we all come
home thank you johnine so good to be
with you guys tonight it's been quite a
week of lots of people um either coming
down with things or traveling or being
sick so I'm really really grateful that
tonight um my friend AJ um has
volunteered to help us out on guitar and
singing tonight so if you guys could
just welcome him he's like someone very
near and dear to my heart at all times
and it's been quite a while since we got
to play together so it's been a real
gift to have him jump in tonight with us
so just wanted to say that's who this
guy is right here this is AJ um would
you guys stand with us we're going to
get started with our set and um I just
want to remind us all that this is a
moment not for music to be performed but
for worship to be entered into this is a
space for us to bring all that we've
carried with us this week out before God
and before each other and to lift it up
and to make space for what's going on in
our hearts and minds and hopefully
interact and meet with the love of God
in a community where there's room for
you um so we just invite you guys to
enter into that with us so all right
we're going to get started on glorious
day so you guys can follow AJ and here
we
go I was bued
beneath my
[Music]
shame who could carry that kind
of
way it was
my till I met
you I was
breathing but
not
alive all my failures I
tried to hide
it was
my till I met
you you called my
name and I ran out of that
way out of the
darkness into your glorious
day you call my
i r out of
that out of of the
darkness into your glorious
day now your mercy has
saved my
[Music]
soul now your freedom is all
that I
know the old made
new Jesus when I made
[Music]
you you call my
name and I went out of that
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
name you called my
name and I ran out of
that out of the
darkness into your glorious
[Music]
day I needed resue my sin was heavy but
chains break at the weight of Your Glory
I needed
shelter I was in
nor you call me a
citizen when I was broken you were my
healing now your love is the air that
I'm breathing I have a future My Eyes
Are Open cuz when you call my
name I out that
out of the
darkness into your glorious
day you called my
name and I ran out of that
grave yeah out of the
darkness into your glorious
[Music]
all right you kiddos are dismissed to go
to your
classes Charlie what's so
funny bye guys thank you kids ministry
team so much for loving on those guys
give your teachers big hugs and thank
you be nice to
them all right and we are going to
transition into the prayers of the
people so if this is your first time
with us this is just an opportunity for
us to name the things that we are
carrying into this space together so if
you'll follow along on the screens the
parts that we read aloud together are
all in red so you can join in on those
parts and then we'll leave some space in
the middle for you to speak out loud a
name or a situation that's heavy on your
heart tonight and then we'll close the
prayer together at the end
Jesus for this city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and Des
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss and loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we we pray to you Lord we know
that you love us and that you hear us so
we lift these names and situations up to
you Johnny Owen
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
I raise the
hallelu in the presence of my
enemies I raise a
hallelu louder than the
unbelief I raise a Hallelujah
my weapon is a
Melody I raise a
Hallelujah Heaven comes to fight for me
let's sing this out and I'm going to
sing in the middle of the
stor louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Roar
Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king
[Music]
is raise the
Hallelujah with everything inside of
me I raise a Hallelujah
and I will watch The
[Music]
Darkness I raise a
Hallelujah in the middle of the
mystery I raise a
Hallelujah fear you lost your hold on
me and I'm going to sing in the middle
of the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Ro Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
[Music]
alive sing a little louder
sing a little
louder sing a little
louder we sing a little louder we're
going to sing a little
louder of my enemy sing a little
louder louder than the sing a little
louder my is a Mel sing a little
louder Heaven comes to fight for me sing
a little
louder in the presence of my enemy sing
louder louder than the unbel sing a
little
louder it is a Melody sing a little
louder
heav comes
to sing a little
louder I'm going to sing in the middle
of the
stor louder and louder going to hear my
Praises Ro Up From the Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive I'm going to sing in the middle of
stor louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises
Ro From the Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive I raise a
Hallelujah I raise Hallelujah yeah I
raise a
Hallelujah I raise Hall Hallelujah I
Hallelujah I raise a Hallelujah I raise
a
Hallelujah I raise the
hallelu I raise the
hallelu I ra the
hallelu I raise a
hallelu let's raise a
hallelu raise a
Hallelujah
hallelu I raise Hallelujah
we lift it up
tonight lift our hearts and lift our
[Music]
SS we it up to you
God
sh go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
m that he is
go
shout go and screaming from the mountain
going and tell it to
[Music]
the that he is
god let's sing that again lift it
up
shout
it go on and scream it from the
M go on and tell it to the Man
that He
Is We Shout It Out Shout It Out
Shout
It Go and scream it from the
mountain going and tell it to the
m that he is God
and we will sing out
huah we will cry out High
huah we will sing out
[Music]
[Applause]
Hallelujah yeah we will sing our high
lah we will cry out
High We Will Sing Out
[Music]
hallelu
shout oh we cry to
you we pour our hearts out to you
[Music]
oh cuz you're a
God cry to
you it up it
outout
it cry to you
[Music]
and from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
m he
is Shout It Out shout it outout
go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell to
[Music]
the that he
is I'm
sing in the middle of the
storm louder and
Lou you're going to hear our
Praises up from
the hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
[Music]
alive God we lift up our hearts and our
stories
the events that have led us to this
moment right here God the
pain the
victories the
defeats the
mistakes we bring our whole selves
before you tonight knowing god that you
have made space and room for it all that
you have invited each one of us as a
whole
person to be children of God
to be seen and
known to be loved and
accepted and God Even in our
Brokenness Even in our
sin or the things that drive us apart
from each other our
Wars our fights our arguments our
politics even even there God we choose
tonight to come together in this space
and say that love is the thing that
paves the way love is the hope that
anchors
us love is the
beauty that we want to find that we want
to live
into that we want to live out
[Music]
God so despite all the ways that we mess
it up that we miss the
Mark tonight God would you cover us in
your
love would you bring us together under
your banner where everyone has a
place where everyone is wanted
and God when we lift our voices and when
we cry out to you we know that we're
crying to a God who hears us who sees
us and we hold on to that
God in our doubt in our
[Music]
disbelief we hold on to you
and we ask that you would keep doing
your good work here in
Us in Jesus name
amen will you guys welcome the people
around you say hello and then Brett will
start our message
Grace and peace oh yes welcome welcome
to the table so glad to be with you all
my name is Brett pronounce he him and uh
the pastor here and it's just a joy joy
to welcome you into this space and uh as
always that includes those join us
online y'all are not forgotten and don't
forget to get your communion stuff for
later in the service uh got some wine
there at the house then uh that could
come in handy and uh also want to
welcome uh those of you who are new this
is your first time or just your first
time in a long time we're uh really
really glad that you're that you're here
hope you feel uh just I don't know feel
a sense of Welcome um and sense the the
love of God in this place so um we are
in the season of epiphany in the church
calendar and uh this is not I would say
it's not one of the more famous seasons
in the church a lot of people know about
like lent or Advent maybe but you know
Epiphany is often skipped over um but
it's it's really a season about the the
Revelation the unveiling of Christ in
the world and uh kind of a time to
reflect on how that that Light of Christ
um leads us forward invites us uh into
the more that God has for us so um with
that in mind the title of my message
this week is six society and secret joy
and our passage is Luke chapter 6: 17-
26 and it reads Jesus went down with
them and stood on a level place a large
crowd of his disciples was there and a
great number of people from all over
Judea from Jerusalem and from the
coastal region around tier and sedone
who had come to hear him and to be
healed of their diseases those troubled
by impure Spirits were cured and the
people all tried to touch him because
power was coming from him and he healing
them
all looking at his disciples he said
blessed are you who are poor for yours
is the kingdom of God blessed are you
who hunger now for you will be satisfied
blessed are you who weep now for you
will laugh blessed are you when people
hate you and when they exclude you and
insult you and reject your name as evil
because of the son of man rejoice in
that day leap for Joy because great is
your reward in heaven for that is how
their ancestors treated the
prophets but woe to you who are rich for
you have already received your
comfort woe to you who are wellfed now
for you will go hungry woe to you who
laugh now for you will mourn and weep
woe to you when everyone speaks well of
you for that's how their ancestors
treated the false prophet
prophets so this is a it's a fascinating
and honestly a somewhat confusing text
um I think that the middle part in
particular though the ending has its own
bite but that middle part in particular
is where I want to focus blessed are you
who are poor blessed are you who hunger
now blessed are you who weep blessed are
you when people hate
you it just sounds crazy you know it
just sounds like nonsensical like just
you know being poor that's bad being
hungry is bad being sad is bad being
hated that's bad in fact I don't know
about you but I think you know I spend
the vast majority of uh our lives like
attempting to counter what like
precisely those States right I I spend
all week trying not to be
poor trying not to be hungry like avoid
that at all cost trying not to be weepy
sad hated excluded this is like my life
project so it kind of begs the question
like what the heck Jesus like what are
you getting at here so what I want to do
is kind of come at this sideways we want
to take kind of go through like the
historical path I don't know if this
will land for you I hope it does but um
hopefully you can see that we're we're
getting somewhere with this so let's go
way back in time like way back there is
a lot of debate among
anthropologists about the details of
early human societies and like you know
what we might call like deep history but
uh but the broad Strokes are fairly
clear fairly well known known um and
agreed upon what we do know is that for
hundreds of thousands of years Homo
sapiens lived um I would say was much
closer kind of a much simpler life um
than we live and because of that
probably by default closer to the heart
of this passage um it was a more
communal way of living a bit more eist
way right because there just was no
wealth to really be had right there just
wasn't a lot of power there's really no
hierarchy or very little you know um no
real consumption to like Chase so
everyone was poor most everyone was
powerless because everyone lived in
these kind of hunter gatherer groups you
know and
um kind of going as like weather and
Wild game
dictated right moving here and there it
was just a very simple life so for the
vast majority of our history while I
don't think just to be clear humans have
ever been perfect or something um I do
think there was less addiction uh less
power games less ego more peace more
quiet more in tuned with the spirit um
than in modern times I think you see
that in at least the best of indigenous
cultures um it kind shows a lot of this
so what happened well then about 12,000
years ago um which of course to us that
sounds like forever you know like 12,000
years oh my gosh it's like forever no no
no right because we're talking as
compared to hundreds of thousands of
years actually 12,000 of 300,000 is like
4% so you could say for the last little
sliver of time 96% of our history was
very different now 4% of our time uh
things have changed right you had the
rise of Agriculture suddenly instead of
moving here and there now you had more
permanent settlements and then
eventually the rise of cities um hang
with me don't worry I'm going somewhere
and you're like what do do with the
bages all right now you have increasing
wealth right and and you have uh not 150
humans living together like no no that's
that's gone right now we have thousands
and then tens of thousands and now you
start having these like major
technological um advances right in food
production and other Tech kind of
upgrades and things but also of course
in weapons in Warfare and then you have
the rise of Empires like the first known
as like the Acadian Empire and then
pretty soon after that the Assyrians
they dominated for like over a thousand
years and then the Babylonians now
you're into Bible times right if you
recognize some of those terms you know
like some of your old testament uh
you're into the the biblical kind of era
so um you have these Empires right and I
would describe Empires they're sort of
like um at least at first they're kind
of like Psychopathic human societies not
that everyone in the Empire is like
they're a psychopath as like an
individual I just mean that the Empire
itself sort of functions in um ways that
profoundly lack empathy right a sort of
oh I feel your pain your pain is like my
pain you know
like no that's when you think imp Empire
you don't think like oh yeah empathy you
so because that it's quite Psychopathic
um so the Empire itself right it
functions in this way it's a sort of
real
politic um that says okay look um I have
to
assume that everyone is out to get me I
have to assume that that other group
they're amassing
technology right they're amassing
weapons they're potentially planning to
eliminate me even if they're not I have
to assume that they are right it's sort
of so it's probably smart for me to go
ahead and attack them first before they
get stronger now can you see where this
logic sort of starts to play out in
world history so fast forward to today
and what you have is this like
bizarre
world where we have all these problems
that no one
wants and even people say like we've got
to solve this and yet we're just kening
over the edge of the cliff no one wants
climate change no one wants poverty no
one wants war no one wants
misinformation no one wants an economy
built on addiction no one wants nuclear
weapons no one wants species after
species to go extinct no one wants the
rainforce to be cut down no one wants us
to make like some crazy mistake with AI
cuz we're just like oh we got to beat
the other guy a you know hurry hurry
hurry hurry you know like no one wants
this to happen like we want the best of
it hopefully you know but not the worst
of it so no one wants this but the
problem is I'm worried I'm worried that
if I back
off if I don't hunt the whales or cut
down the rainforest or extract the
resources or prepare for nuclear war
well then that other
guy uh I use that gender on purpose that
other guy that other culture Society you
know China or whoever the you know they
will they will they're going to and so
for the sake of National Security I must
pursue these
things we must collectively act
psychopathically we must lack empathy
because if we do not we're going to
weaken ourselves and we're going to be
conquered by the other human culture
acting more psychopathic than
us so what I'm driving at is I think the
story of human history I don't think
it's one of kind of straightforward
progress you know it's like yes it's all
been delightful I mean maybe 150 years
ago or so people could be more naive and
sort of optimistic about that um like oh
technology it's just purely wonderful
you know now we realize like it's LED
this kind of insane arms
race where we we just keep kind of um
pushing this crazy path but we're unable
to stop because of our we're competitive
with
others I I think in short I would say we
are
ill modern culture is ill modern
societies all over the globe I'm not
just picking on the us we're
ill the spiritual writer J Krishna mty
put it this way he said it is no measure
of Health
to be well adjusted to a profoundly sick
Society now perhaps you feel I'm being
too hard on Modern societies to be clear
I'm not saying there's no beauty or
goodness there personally I really like
penicillin it's great you know it's good
good Tech what I'm contending is that um
there is goody there is goodness there
is beauty there sure but slowly but
surely I think it's it's getting kind of
edged out more and more it's getting
pushed to the margins the best of us the
least narcissistic the least power
hungry the least greedy are marginalized
more and more and
more so what does this have to do with
the Beatitudes this these passages from
Christ I think as Jesus surveyed his own
day in time he could already see this
process well
underway in other words I don't think he
looked at human cities and cultures and
said oh wow
they're
perfect how wonderful they are no I
think he could already see the poor
being edged out he could already see
things like empathy and beauty and love
being edged out in favor of more
makavelian ways of being Cutthroat ways
of being I mean think of it the Son of
God the most pure perfect and lovely
human being ever
was put on a cross and tortured to
death how ill do you think human
societies
are
sick sick and so in the Beatitudes Jesus
I think is saying look you're blessed
you're blessed if you're finding it hard
to adjust to a sick Society
you see some of you
have said look I'm not going to make
money the center of my life I'll earn a
living I want a a noble profession but
but I refuse to put that front and
center instead I want to help I want to
serve so if what I'm doing is not
serving and helping the world then I
want no part of it and you may have
suffered for that you may be struggling
to pay your bills it may not be
celebrated by your family you may not be
making your parents proud why because
they've been indoctrinated into the ways
of this
world but Jesus says you're blessed
because of
that you're blessed because of
that some some of you survey the world
and it brings tears to your
eyes you're the Weeping
ones you grieve at the mess we have
gotten ourselves into there's something
in Christian history it's known as the
gift of
Tears it's actually a highly
coveted State oh to be able to tune into
God's
heart and express it through
tears that's a
gift and Christ
says you're
blessed because of
that some of you find yourselves deeply
hated and
excluded the sick Society always needs
someone to fear someone to be against
politically to Rally the base I think of
right now my immigrant friends my lgbtq
friends black and brown friends it's a
sick
Society or maybe you're excluded because
you're trying to follow Jesus right
you're trying to raise the alarm and say
hey we have got to stop acting in
Psychopathic tribal ways we've got to
stop this we have to be about something
more than simply National Security
winning at all costs no matter what lies
and misinformation we spread in the
process we got to be about something
more than fear fear fear fear fear
you're pushing back on the psychopathy
of modern society and Jesus says oh
you're blessed you're blessed you're
blessed because of that you're you're
blessed when you're hated and excluded
because of me it's the way of the world
Jesus told us this is how they've been
treating the prophets for 12,000
years so he says don't be too shocked I
warned
you now you may be wondering where's the
blessing the Greek word translated as
blessing is marcaras which means well
blessed or happy or Blissful depending
on your translation and it actually
carries a kind of a a sort of divine
connotation in other words it's like a
like a spirit in infused God infused
kind of blessing or um blissfulness so
so what do we make of this well verse 23
says rejoice in that day and leap for
Joy because great is your reward in
heaven so I I do think this is part of
it right there will be an eternal reward
for remaining faithful to Christ and not
giving in to this increasingly
Psychopathic culture that there will be
an eternal reward for not going down the
path of evil uh but of course this begs
the question like well what about now
you know I just live in misery for 5060
years and then
hope for heaven you well I I do think um
I do think that we over time I do think
we can begin to get the blessings now I
I think of Psalm uh 30:5 which says
weeping may last for night but a shadow
of Joy comes in the
morning there is a joy that comes to
those who reject the way of the world
and instead choose the way of Christ
there is a joy that comes to those who
reject the way of the world and choose
Instead The Joy the path of
Christ and in fact one of the marks of a
true Saint is uh precisely their Joy I
think this is one of the great tragedies
of Christian history that when we
envision like you know church leaders or
even like Saints you know we kind of
holy people you know we get this kind of
picture of someone who's just like you
know be quiet in church you know or
something uh when actually the saint is
uh known precisely for their Joy that's
how that's part of the indicator that
they're a
saint is precisely that Joy so yes they
may be poor they may weep they may even
have the gift of Tears um they may be
hated but in going through that what
happens hear me they begin to root
themselves in something deeper
God and God is the source of all
joy God is the source of all
joy to give you a modern example the uh
the Buddhist poet activist teacher and
Saint tikn Han I link to his books and
my e-l letters all the time he wrote a a
wonderful book titled peace is every
step I don't know if anyone's read that
but is
good um now I know he's a Buddhist um
but I would still I'd recommend every
person on the planet like read this book
um he's um well I'll say this he's
honestly a little bit challenging to
read for a Westerner um not because he's
writing like academic ways or something
not not at all the book is like super
straightforward not not not academic at
all um but it's
because he's so so darn
happy he just goes on and on and on
about the joy he finds in life I mean
it's literally this whole passages
written about Tangerine
meditation he says
oh this Tangerine is it's so delicious I
like to spend a whole hour eating just
one
tangerine he talks about I mean it's
it's like over the top he um how much
Joy he talks about how much joy he finds
in taking a walk he says oh when I walk
I kiss Mother Earth with every step he
says the world would be a better place
if we could learn to walk with that kind
of Joy I mean it's just he says oh every
day I like to take at least an hour just
for
breathing oh how Blissful it is to
breathe when I don't have a cold he's
like we often don't appreciate how great
it is to breathe until we get a cold and
then we're like if only I could breathe
again you know and it just on and on and
on um now you say well that's cuz I
don't know he's like Buddhist monk guy
or something he's just Bliss out he's
just happy and you know everything's
great in his life you know um no no no
no no no no no no um so he if you go
back 40 years he um did something called
uh engaged Buddhism he wanted them to
get out of the monasteries and he wanted
them to be in the midst of the people
specifically in the Vietnam War so
bullets flying over his head canoeing
from Village to Village like
dangerous trauma inducing War I mean
difficult he ultimately was actually
exiled from Vietnam for 40 years because
both sides opposed him because he
opposed both of them because he's like
bullets and bombs are not the way to
solve this gentlemen you know and
they're like well we hate you so this is
I guess the one thing they agreed on is
this guy needs to go um he's he's
thankful honestly to escape with his
life uh exiled to France lived there um
for 40 or 39 years and uh it was not it
was not always easy you can read his
biography not always easy oh but he was
happy he was
blessed blessed Blissful why how because
he had
God he had God I don't know your
theology about people of other religions
all I know is when I read pieces every
step I said my God this man is is
putting me to shame this man is full of
the Holy
Spirit or take Jesus I'll close with
this did he have his moments of grief
and sadness of course of course it's a
tough tough
life but did Jesus walk around just
miserable all the time no no in fact I
would contend that if you met Jesus
you'd probably be surprised by how much
he
smiled I mean everyone wanted to be
around him everyone one was drawn to
him you're not drawn to people who are
just like right no his Joy his Joy he
was full of the Holy Spirit full of God
and God is the source of all
joy so what do I want you to do this
week I want you to take 15 minutes to
enjoy a simple pleasure with full
awareness it could be coffee but like
really paying attention to it it could
be writing out a
scripture walking you want to kiss
Mother Earth with your feet you do
whatever you want you know but but the
point is I want you to like really show
up for that moment and practice that
even in the midst of the crazy even in
the midst of a psychopathic culture and
world and all that that's still God is
to be found and we can root
ourselves in Christ in that so Church
may we be the poorest weepest most
despised happiest Church on the
planet in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples at that meal he held up a loaf
of bread he broke it and he said this is
my body it's broken for you and he held
up a cup of wine said this is my blood
it's shed for you whenever you eat this
bread whenever you drink this cup
remember me so as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight may we do it with
awareness may we do it with joy may we
do it to sink ourselves into something
deeper than just life in society may it
ground Us in the personal work of Christ
so the way we'll take communion tonight
we'll just go row by row starting here
at the front we'll form a line
um right here um we practice an open
table so if you're here tonight you want
to participate you are free to do that
regardless of your exact denomination or
Christian background or or whatever um
if um if you want to connect with Christ
you're you're welcome to participate in
this time you should know the red is
wine the white is grape juice and then
finally you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like some folks like
to come and kneel um others prefer to
return to their seats or just take it
immediately so this is the table not the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
come you who have much faith and you who
have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
we're going to close tonight with a song
that we learned last week called uh we
will feast in the house of z y I really
wish that Nate was here because this was
his like brainchild and um in both weeks
he's traveling right now on tour I can't
wait for us to do the song with him but
um in the meantime if you remember last
week we talked about how Zion was this
it it was both symbolic and it was an
actual place where King David um in
battle was able to take territory take
that territory and it became this
representation of of where God would
gather his people and
restore what had been lost and when we
sing about the house of Zion tonight
it's us longing for that
restoration um I loved that quote that
Brett read I can't remember who the
author was but you know about it being
crazy to be well adjusted to a sick
Society um I I wrote it down so that I
can go back and and look it back up
but we have so much sickness around us
but as children of God we have this hope
that there will be restoration that he
is bringing about not only in like the
Hereafter or the life to come or you
know someday but right now in our world
when we stand as children of God loved
seen known accepted that we are bringing
Zion we are bringing restoration to the
sick and the broken places in US to the
sick and broken places in our world in
our communities so if you guys would
stand with us we're going to sing this
song one more time together and um join
in as you learn it or if you remember
from last week I I invite you to join in
and let's hope um that God will continue
to do that work today and in our futures
[Music]
Sing We Will Feast we will feast in the
House Of
Z we will see and Lord
restored he has done great things we
will
say
together we we will Fe and weep no
more we will not
be by the
fire he is the Lord Our
God we are not
consumed by the
[Music]
flood
uphel
protected G gaed
up we will feast in the house of
s we will sing with our hearts
restor he has done great things we will
say
together we will feast and weep no
more in the dark of night
before the
time my soul be night of
fi for the promis
morning oh how
long oh god of
jaob be my
strength we will feast in the house of Z
we will see with our hearts
restored he has done great things we
will
say
together we will feast and we no
more no
more
oh no oh
[Music]
no
every and
betray you are the faithful
one and from the
guide and to the gra
find us together bring
shom we will feast in the house of
Zion we will see with our hearts
restored he has done great things we
will
stay
together we will be
and weep no
more we'll weep no
[Music]
more we will weep no
more we weep no more
[Music]
thank you all so much for joining us
this evening we are so glad to see you
here and if you're a firsttime visitor
or visitor that like to leave your
information there's uh some little cards
over on the little table or you can scan
the QR code and fill out a online
visitors card so we can just touch base
with you
uh we can all use more relational
support and spiritual connection and so
the way we do that here at the table is
via the our meetup groups so if you are
not part of a Meetup you can scan the QR
code and find one that fits your time
and your schedule and you can find out
uh more about
them generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship if the
table is your church home then we invite
you to scan the QR code and give
financially or visit the tax.org
and now let me send you into your week
with this
blessing you can hold out your hands in
a posture of receiving or you can just
open your hearts to these
words you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything else in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are and
go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with be blessed
and we hope to see you back next
week
Z we will see with our hearts r
he has done great things we will
say
together we will go and we know we will
feast in the house of
Zion we will sing with our hearts
restored he has done great things we
will
see
together we will be
and we' no
more no
more
oh no
oh no more
[Music]
he